I Tanya the movie about Tonya Harding
yes she is there you went to the Globes
Tonya Harding was there and so what was
it like to experience the Globes through
someone who's never been in that
position before it was she was like a
kid in a candy store she was her eyes
she couldn't believe who was around her
they jam-packed everyone in there you're
like 20 seats around a table for ten and
everyone is that you're you know
Angelina Jolie's right there and Tom
Hanks is right there in Oprah's over
there and Tonya was so thrilled the only
difference is like I'm thrilled to but I
would never go to talk to anyone because
I know how everyone just just lets it
through this and they don't you know I
never want to presume that no they want
to see me and that's what I think so but
Tonya was like I'm gonna go talk to
Oprah I was like no no come back here
come back and she said she knows me and
and because I guess she interviewed her
back yeah but also everybody knows so
but but not so much so cuz she went over
to Oprah and she came back and I said
how'd that go she said Oprah didn't know
who I was
yeah she didn't recognize sweetie I'm
just picturing Tonya Harding in front of
Oprah going hey what did you just be hey
Oprah it was like she went up to her
like you're your Oprah and you're
returning John Todd yes yes she was like
yeah like this on the elbow you know but
like - Oh bro no one's touched Oprah's
elbow in 20 years you need to release a
dove to talk to Oprah and it's like hey
over it's mates it's time yeah and what
he don't say I think it took her and
Charlie just Tonya Harding and she said
oh my god when she was gracious of
course and right hugged her and she came
back over but Tonya was a little miffed
that she didn't remember he was myth
also Tonya went down the red carpet and
she had a sort of a panic attack on the
red carpet and she said this nice lady
helped me get through the carpet and I
was like oh my god that's um so you know
I'm so glad that someone helped you and
then we're sitting in and into the show
and then this woman comes by and she
goes oh here's the lady come meet my
friend Allison and I said oh you mean
Sharon
nice lady help me how it isn't America
great that's right that's what I say go
you from
you